illüzyon gibi bir şey oldu yürümek
diyordum Sanki yürüyerek gelmek zorunda
kalmış gibi oldum biraz beklettik sizi
Ayşe özlem'inci ben çok bağırmamam
gerekiyor sanırım
Ellerimi nasıl hareket ettireceğimi
bilemediğim için cebime koyuyorum
saygısızlık olarak değil
Eğer
ben buraya doğrudan gelseydim iki
soruyla başlayacaktım bu cümleleri
kurmayacaktım iki sorum var Birincisi
şu; bir ortama girdiğinizde kimler Benim
yürüyüşüm hakkında ne düşünüyor diye
merak ediyor el kaldırabilirler mi bir
ortama girdim ve şu an yürüyüşüm
hakkında ne düşünüyorlar teşekkürler
Peki kim yeni aldığı bir kıyafete
giyip bir ortama girdiğinde şu an nasıl
durdu acaba diye düşünüyor
diye düşünüyoruz Tamam teşekkürler Eğer
ben 11 yaşında sizin huzurunuza
çıksaydım
Benim yürüyüşüm hakkında ne
düşüneceğinizi merak ederdim Çünkü
yürümek benim için yeniden üstüme
aldığım bir eşya bir nesne gibiydi
sebebi şu
10 yaşındayım
Okuldayım teneffüste yerden yüksek
oynuyoruz karşımda Eda arkadaşım var
bana şöyle yapmaya başladı Her şey yavaş
ama
Diyorum ki bu niye böyle komiklik
yapıyor bana şu an ve sesler boklaşmaya
başladı
filmlerde gördüğüm şeyi o an yaşıyordu
sesler bu ok taşıyor herkes yavaş
hareket ediyor Sonra birden Gözlerim
kapandı meğerse üstüme bayrak direği
düşmüş okuldaki
Gözümü bir daha açtığımda
nöbetçi öğretmenim kucağındaydı
kapağında gözüm bir daha açtım
ambulansdayım gözüm bir daha açtım
hastanedeyim Doktorlar yatıyorum
bir anahtar var doktorun elinde sağ ayak
tabanımını çizmeye çalışıyor ben refleks
gösterdim ve ayağımı çektim sonra
anahtarla sol ayak tabanı çizmeye
çalıştı
hissettim Ama hareket ettiremiyordum
belden aşağı felç olmuştu sol tarafı
Doktorlar diyorlar ki hissediyorsan
kıpırdatman gerekiyor Ben de evet
kıpırdatıyorum diyorum bunu yani
ispatlamam gerekiyor Bunu Neyse sonra
tedavi yöntemleri her yere götürdüler
su tedavisinde karar kılındı en sonunda
ben şunu farketmiştim ya ben yürümeye
çalışmıyorum çocuk inadıyla derdim şu
Ben doktora hissettiğimi ispatlamak
zorundayım yani Halbuki yürüdüm yani
sonuca git Aslında
sonra bunu çözmem gerekiyor diye
düşündüm gündüzleri genelde
annemler üzülmesinler diye onların
gözünün önünde ya da böyle sokağa
çıkmadan önce yanıma uğrayan
arkadaşlarım benim için üzülmesinler
diye asla bacaklarımı hareket ettirmek
istemezdim yapmazdım Bunu herkes gece
uyurken ben böyle hareketler yapmaya
çalışırdım bir gece herkes uyurken
yürüyorum diye bağırdım herkes koştu
yanıma
baktılar hala yataktayım Aslında ben sol
ayağımdaki parmaklarıma küçücük
kıpırdatmıştım benim için Çünkü
kıpırdatmak doktordan böyle kalmış
aklımda yürümek anlamına geliyor demek
ki bundan sonrası yapıyorum bu iş bende
diye düşündüm
devam etti devam etti sonra artık ayağa
kalkmaya başladığımda sol ayak tabanı mı
tam olarak yere koyamasam da
sürüklüyordum sağ ayağa atıyorum Sol
Ayağım bayağı bir tavaf ediyor her yeri
geziniyor sonra yanıma geliyor falan
derken ben bu olayı açtım sporcu oldum
hentbol oynadım senelerce bir ara ben
kamu yönetimi okumak istiyordum kendimi
spor akademisinde buldum 14 sene Geçen
seneye de beden eğitimi Hani yaptım Bu
sırada şöyle bir şey oldu
hentbol oynarken tabi başıma ciddi bir
iş geldiği için annemler tereddüt
ediyorlar Aman nasıl olur diye ilk kez
deplasmana gideceğim Mersin deplasmanı
ve beni göndereceklerini düşünmüyorum
hemen kendime baktım bir tane ajanda
buldum boş evde ve onu günlük haline
getirdim ve şöyle yazdım Sevgili günlük
Keşke annemler benim Mersin'e
gönderseler de da dedim falan bir
şeylerdi orada duygusal olan şeyler ve
gittim onların görebileceği bir yere bu
gizli dediğimiz Günlüğü Ortaya koydum ve
uyumaya gittim uyuma numarası yaptım
Beni deplasmanda gönderdiler Sanırım ilk
kez herkes beni okusun yazdıklarımı
okusun Dediğim an o anda
aradan zaman geçti sadece kitap
okuyordum işte beden eğitimi
öğretmenliği yapıyorum en son çalıştığım
okulda özel durum olan bir öğrencim
vardı selebral pelsili ve Walker
sayesinde hayata tutunabiliyordu
Beden eğitim derslerinde genelde yani
pedagojik formasyonu size verdiği
yetkiye dayanarak her şeyi
kullanmalısınız ve bu öğrencilerin
kendisini kötü hissetmemesini
sağlamaksınız tabii ki bir özel durumu
da vardı benim için ayrıca Çocukluğumda
yürüyemediğim için
trambolindi konu ve istiyorum ki ayak
tabanını o yaylara değdirsin ve o da bu
anı Yaşasın özellikle
hayat bana böyle bir fırsat vermişti ya
da ben bile istiyor bunu yapmıştım ben
geçmişte Yaşadım ve edeyim tecrübelerle
o öğrencinin ayak tabanı gerçekten
trambolinde değildi yani senkronize bir
coşku yaşamıştık bunun için teşekkür
ettiğim hayatta nadirenlerden bir tanesi
ve sonra elbette diğer öğrencilerimle
birlikte bu şekilde devam ettim
seneler içerisinde Şöyle düşündüm bu
arada yani ben bunu nasıl çözebilirim
yürümeye başladıktan sonra yürümek benim
için artık bir araçtı Ama mesela takım
sporu oynadım hentbol 14 tane farklı
karakter var ve Bazen sizin
dediklerinizi anlamıyor olabilirler Biz
Düşünsenize geceniz gündüzdünüz onlarla
kimi zaman kampa gidiyorsunuz anlaşılmak
adına kendime yeni yöntemler aradım ve
yazmak bunlardan bir tanesiydi ama
kitabım olsun diye yazmadım elbette
böyle değildi
sonra şunu düşünüyorum Tabii ki bugün
mesela sabahki oturumda olanlar varsa
iklim krizine dair bir konuşma vardı
sivil toplum kuruluşlarına dair insanlar
bireysel değil de bazen de kendi
fikirlerine ait hissettikleri
topluluklarla birlikte yürüyüşler
yapıyorlar Bu neden olabilir mesela
kadınlar yürüdüler İran'da
belli günler oluyor geleneksel ülkelerin
geleneksel günleri olabiliyor
hukuksuzluğa inanıyorsanız dikkat çekmek
için o belli mecralara adresleri
yürüyebilirsiniz
yürüyüşlerin böyle bir sadece oksijen
alıp karbondioksit vermemizin sağlayan
bir böyle enstrüman dışında da böyle bir
durumu var
bunlarla birlikte
şunu düşünüyorum ben
kamerada arkamı dönüyorum çok değişik
oldu böyle şöyle bir durum var benim
için yürümek sadece
Yani
başım işte beynimdekileri boşaltabilmem
gereken bir şey değil Evde oturup
yazarken hikaye yazarken ya da senaryo O
her neyse çalışırken birden kalkıp evin
içinde yürüdüğümü görebiliyorum fark
ediyorum bunu ya da bir sahile atıp
kendime orada gerçekten sanki jetondan
böyle jetonlar düşercesine böyle
fikirlerin geldiğini hayal edebiliyorum
Geçen gün ya dedim Benim konuşmam var
yürümek temalı senin için bir yönetmen
arkadaşım var benden bence yani sanatsal
olarak çok daha kademli Biri senin için
yürümek nasıl dedim yani yaratırken
falan nasıl etki ediyor dedi ki Özlem
yürümeden yapamam yani inanılmaz bir şey
bir trans hali aklım o sırada o sırada
çözemeseniz bile sonrasında Gerçekten
sizi harekete geçiyor geçiriyor yürümek
çocukken beni yaptığı gibi
şöyle düşünüyorum
Elbette Bu arada sahil ve parklarda
yürüyenlerin hepsi sanatçılar değildir
Elbette bazen Mesela birisiyle Artık
görüşmek istemediğinizi söylemek
istediğinizde ya da bir doğum günü
organizasyonu içinde yürürseniz tabii
kimsenin telefonda konuşmadan Bence
böyle böyle de yararları olabilir diye
düşünüyorum şöyle
yürümeyi kullanmak için sanatçı olmanıza
gerek yok bugün Siz evden dışarı
çıktığınız andan buraya gelinceye kadar
Aslında ayaklarınızla Yazdığınız bir
hikaye başlatmış oluyorsunuz ben böyle
düşünüyorum yani evet ben ayaklarımla
nasıl elimdeki kalemi elimi kullanarak
kalemle birlikte bir hikaye yazıyorsam
ayaklarımda da gittiğim yollarda bir
hikaye yazıyorum mesela karşılaştığım
biriyle mi konuşuyorum merhaba diyalog
var burada siz bir yere oturdunuz şu an
mesela yanınızdaki biriyle
konuşuyorsunuz ben görüyorum ve diyorum
ki şu an beni birisi dinlemiyordu işte
Tanrı anlatıcı o sırada Oturduğum yerden
bunu yönlendiriyorum yürürken
peki peki Özlem sağ yürüyemeseydim Bir
de yürüyemeyenler var onlar için ne
söylerdin diye düşünürseniz diye soracak
olursanız da şöyle sınırsız hayal gücü
Ben yürüyemediğim zamanlarda Hayal
gücüme büyük bir yatırım yaptığımı
düşünüyorum Öyle ki yürüyemediğim bir
zaman
çocukken o yürüyemediğim dönemde bir
gece rüyamda Türkiye haritasını
düşünelim işte Ankara başkent orada var
işte Diyarbakır Hatay her yer Orada ve
rüyanda şunu gördüm bingöllüyüm bir su
kaydırağı harita boyunca kaydırağın
merdivenleri Bingöl'de Yürüyemiyorum ya
ucu da İzmir'de Ben su kaydırağına
biniyorum hop şöyle İzmir'de denize
dökülüyorum resmen diyorum ki demek ki
orada bilinçaltında yürüyemiyorsam
yüzebilirim diye düşünüyorum Bir de su
tedavisi herhalde o dönem görüyorsam
herhalde öyle bir iyileştirici olduğun
hayal gücü ila yürümemiz gerekmiyor
hayal gücü uçsuz bucaksız gerçekten
William Black diye sevdiğim bir şair
vardır mesela o şiirinde bir şiirinde
Amerika'ya gitmeden
Amerika'yı anlatmıştır ve çok başarılı
bir şiirdir imgeleleri çok güçlüdür
Hakan Günday çok iyi bir yazardır Belki
sizin dijital mecralarda takip
ettiğinizde Belki de beğendiğiniz
dizilerin senaristlerinden biri onu bir
pod kessin dinlediğimde
ödüllü bir kitabı var kitabında
Almanya'dan bahsetmiş ve şöyle diyor Ben
Almanya'ya o kadar anlattım anlattım
yokuşlar dedim abi diyor gittim ben
Almanya'da Almanya'da yokuş yok ama bu
Tabii ki Hayal gücünün gidip görmeden
bile nasıl Etkin kullanılabildiğine dair
çok güzel bir işaret Bana kalırsa
Ben de şunu fark ettim Hakan Gülay onu
söyledikten sonra bir kitabım var
ve şey
13 Öykü'den 11'inde Ben yürümekten kimi
karakterleri yürütmüşüm ben sürekli
sürekli kitabımın adına baktım yerin
dibinden geliyorum yine geliyor sürekli
bir gelme hali buraya ile kafayı
bozmuşum Yani orayı çözene kadar onun
üstüne gitmişim
şöyle
büyük lafları etmek istemiyorum Buraya
mesela çıktığımda da çok Ödüm Kopuyor
Hele ki bir okulda etkinlik varsa Melin
malı bunu yapmalısınız bu yapma işte bu
olmalı falan Bu tür şeylerden gerçekten
sakınıyorum
ben bu hikayemi anlatarak Aslında sizin
hayatınızda yürümek Belki de yürümek
kadar güçlü olabilecek şey nedir Ve onun
üzerine Gidebilir misiniz diye Aslında
bir pencere açmak istedim Edip Cansever
var vardı Çok biliyorsunuzdur diye
düşünüyorum
İyi bir şair Bence şiirleriyle Aslında
hikaye anlatıcısı gibidir Onun bir sözü
var der ki bizlere dadanan her yakıcı
umutsuzluk her küs daha acı
bizde bir yaşama direncine bir mutluluğa
dönüşmek zorunda anlam da biz de
anlamsızlıkta
Ben genelde
kimi çıkmazlardı bu cümleye gerçekten
hep kendime Kılavuz edinirim bir de şu
var son kez yani Son olarak şunu
söylemek istiyorum
yazarak Ben her zaman şunu diledim ve en
baştan yazarken de yazmaya başladığımda
İçimden hep şunu dilerdim ilk kez böyle
söylüyorum bu arada
Ben öyle şeyler yazayım ki
okuyan kişi de gerçekten bir hisse Öyle
bir etki yaratayım ki bir şeyi harekete
geçireyim ve o kişi de buradan
etkilenerek kendisine dair yapabileceği
en güçlü şey kendi has bir şekilde
yapsın ve ona tanıklık edenler de bu
şekilde başkalarına ulaşsınlar Ben bir
kişiye Belki bugün ulaşacağım O bir kişi
Belki çok iyi bir müzisyen olacak ve
seri olacak ve pek çok kişiye hitap
edecek Umarım bu konuşmanın sonunda beni
bu şekilde hatırlarsınız ve böyle bir
Eskimo olur Teşekkür ederim